originally from a small town in central
Kentucky and I came to Columbia because
I knew that there was something else out
there and I wasn't quite sure what it
was but I knew there was something else
out there I wanted to reach out as far
as I could while I had the opportunity
there are two things about Colombia that
for me make it a singular experience and
make it a truly amazing institution the
first is the diversity of the
institution that the student body is
really a mirror of New York in all of
its diversity and all of its intensity
his argument the second thing is a small
class of with truly outstanding faculty
members where you're getting to share
your own thoughts about particular texts
or particular issues with someone who's
literally the world expert in a field
and twelve people within your own age
range and that's an amazing experience I
mean not only are you in the city that
is the most international and global
perspective in the world but one of the
nation's top universities in terms of
academics in terms of professors in
terms of course opportunities what made
me choose Colombia was the dynamics of
the city and the dynamics of the program
Colombia was a perfect place to explore
all different ideas being able to
interact with different people and
knowing learning how to apply my
engineering education it's really
challenging you do have to work really
hard you get so much out of it there's a
kind of real emphasis here on the
classics and classical tradition and
classical study the idea that what
you're studying has been important not
just in the last 10 years but for the
last 2,000 3,000 years and so you're
reading Plato's symposium and you're
walking past Butler library looking up
and see Plato's name etched in the
library and you think well like I'm
really part of something special at this
school
it is in many ways an institution unlike
any other founded as King's College on
the banks of the Hudson in 1754 it is
the fifth oldest institution of higher
learning in America and the first in New
York City at one time or another its
faculty and students have included
Alexander Hamilton and Theodore
Roosevelt Lou Gehrig and James Cagney
Margaret Mead and Enrico Fermi Richard
Rogers Lorenz Hart and Oscar Hammerstein
all had a hand in the varsity show of
1920 this is a university that is not
shy about getting out there in the world
it basically was conceived that way that
it was in the world and that it was
going to be involved Columbia University
in the city of New York is rightly named
the two are wedded to one another the
strength of Columbia's fabric has so
much to do with the fact that the whole
place is a twerking laboratory for
anyone teaching literature drama or
dance in my case music - we're lucky at
Columbia we can instead of putting
paintings on the slides in class we can
go to the Met and actually you know get
our nose close to the painting and
really look at the brushstrokes my
internship with the women's rights
division of Human Rights Watch it's
actually stationed in the Empire State
Building so I get to take the two down
every morning with all the the financial
district all the lawyers and then head
down Empire State Building and do my
internship there everybody seems to pass
through New York everybody comes here
everything's available here and I feel
that way about Columbia that it's just a
mecca in a way for the intellectual
world
the campus is Morningside Heights and
the campus is New York City and given
our population and given the way New
York is in the way Columbia is so many
people study abroad so many people come
from other parts of the country or in
other parts of the world your campus
really is the entire world
you have a different kind of student
body at Columbia resonating to the
energy of the city and to the rigor of
the curriculum and that's a potent
combination I think that's from my point
of view what's different and special
about Columbia what do you make of this
book what you make of the solider by I
mean how does it strike it the core is
the center of your Columbian it's a
range of books
beginning with the Iliad and the Odyssey
through the Greeks all the way until you
get your Virginia Woolf you know
everything I mean it's it's just a broad
spectrum you leave thinking that you can
read anything
you literally leave there thinking that
there is no piece of literature that you
can't master the core curriculum is
really a collection of courses in a
variety of disciplines designed to
introduce undergraduates to a whole
array of intellectual activity that we
would define as culture and come back
and teach their communities as the
enlightened ones some of it historical
some of it in the fine arts some of it
literary and most recently there's been
added the science component all of the
classes were woven together in a way
that I found fabulous from the political
history through the literature through
the music classes that I took in the art
classes for me it just felt like an
awakening a lot of people had or maybe
had already studied classics in a
private school or had read a lot of the
works I hadn't done any of that and so
for me it was invaluable students are
not afraid to think about the things
that they talk about in class and take
it with them everywhere the books were
reading that's what we talk about when
we sit around a dinner
we're gonna go out for drinks and I
think that's amazing something that I
never found anywhere else I mean like
you really like I think the core is
great it helps you a lot with critical
thinking which is actually really
important to an engineer it really
allows you to listen to somebody's
argument and really understand what
they're saying see their strong points
see their weak points and therefore make
a better argument at the end because we
have such a robust liberal arts program
it allows us to integrate our
engineering students into the liberal
arts curriculum and therefore help them
create a special niche for themselves
right off the bat there's a course
called Gateway design you do a design
group with four or five other incoming
freshmen engineers it's a great
introduction to what it means to be an
engineer I've created a very active
service-learning program students
learning by doing by working on projects
that are usually focused on the
community usually has some sort of
social good to it
when a child pulls down on this lever
the other end of it will go up we want
them to consider very carefully the
social ramifications of the products
that they're developing or the
technologies that they're working with
for my senior design project we worked
on a well side unit to remove arsenic
from well water and Bangladesh
that's my chemical engineering side my
biomedical engineering side I've done
different tissue engineering products
people get into design mostly because I
won't help people so that's what
Columbia allows you to do with your
education
the thing that I really like about
Columbia academically for the
undergraduates is you are introduced to
many different subject areas I thought I
would be a political science major and
in my first and second years I just fell
in love with my chemistry courses as an
undergraduate I did research in the
chemistry department and these are
really you know the top chemistry
professors in the world so you really
get a first-hand introduction to what it
would be like to go get a PhD you get to
try on doing a PhD bubbling ions
cm creatinine kinase for normal I feel
that it many of the top research
institutions there is a tension between
doing great research and training great
people and I've always felt that at
Columbia it's really the opposite the
philosophy is that you're gonna do great
scholarship by enabling your students to
really reach their potential as an
undergrad I feel like I've received a
lot more attention and care especially
in terms of academics than I would have
in any other place and really at
Columbia I have never been afraid to
approach a professor or to voice my
opinions about certain things I've never
felt as if for some reason as an
undergrad I my opinion counted for less
yeah we're gonna be with you in a couple
of minutes I just want to catch Sally is
she around in Colombia the doors are
always open you know if I want help on
structure biology I go and see Wayne
Hendrickson or Eric goooo and they
graciously discuss my problems with me
people don't have any hesitation about
revealing the ignorance if they want to
learn something it's just a wonderful
open society for exchange of ideas
come come to your bench there's
something dynamic exciting and open
about Colombia that is absolutely unique
right we have a piano starts off then it
gets up to mezzo piano when the horns
come in and then we build on the bridge
to a metal 14 maybe a 14 really swing it
alright let's take a little faster one
two three four one this is the first
time I came to America I came all the
way from Nairobi Kenya I like Columbia
University because it's beautiful it's
grassy it's trees all over the place
Columbia is kind of a college town in
the middle of Manhattan you get a
feeling that you're actually part of a
community that is something different
than just New York City which is great
because you end up having both my
parents had a few apprehensions about me
coming to college in New York City and I
say that what completely turned it
around was the moment that my father
stepped on to Columbia's campus with me
I could feel him breathe a sigh of
relief and then it was okay for their
daughter to come from Savannah Georgia
to New York City the campus is really
it's a campus you know there are lawns
where everybody sits outside and has
their lunch I would say you know half of
the dormitories are physically located
on the campus you get to meet people
from all across the world totally
different perspectives on life and you
definitely benefit from that my best
friend is from a small town in Alabama
one of my other best friends is actually
from the inner city in Boston and we
lived you know 20 minutes apart from
each other our whole lives we didn't
meet until he came to Columbia and
probably wouldn't have been friends if
we met somewhere else
they're totally different experiences I
think the greatest thing about Columbia
is it's it's incredibly diverse on Aven
get any given day you'll see students
groups out there doing events like to
welcome you to the fifth annual Columbia
community outreach and you know you
really feel like there are multiple
communities that also come together on
ask Columbia people find their own
little niche
you find out that there are student
athletes all over the place you have
your friends that are from your classes
and you have a team and you have people
that know what it's like to go to the
gym and juggle practice and literature
humanities at the same time so it's
pretty cool
you
I think that Colombians are proud not a
group of people that's out really
boastful but they do believe that
they're part of something great and I
think there is an awareness that the
kind of education you're going to get
it's kind of quality to it a texture to
it you cannot be sure about other places
and you're bringing a regular a great
university in a great city and I think
what you have is just something just so
remarkable so wonderful that we're just
all just as lucky as we can be to be
part of it
people have many are awesome I'm
definitely gonna be friends with over
the rest of my life - no doubt in my
mind you meet people who are so
exceptional
people who are incredibly smart we are
gonna do amazing things and you learn
from them I was awarded a fellowship to
do research on a Cuban politics actually
going into Ethiopia through this special
fellowship that Colombia offers so I'm
really excited I have this dream job and
I promise you I will do it my dream job
is working in the United Nations during
logistics Council that's my goal
Columbia doesn't teach you how to be a
writer it doesn't teach you how to be in
my case an actor or in the case of Brian
De Palma a filmmaker Terrence McNally a
playwright what it can do is unlock
something and that's what education is
for it's to release something inside of
you and to make you understand or allow
you to understand that you can do pretty
much anything that you can imagine